You're doing something for willingly
is the fundamental of huge joy,
isn't it?
Hello.
However simpler, stupid, or
you'd your Dick Activity. It is.
I'm doing something willingly makes
a world of difference, isn't it? So
hello,
the difference between
Heaven and Hell is just this.
You are doing something
willingly that you're having.
You're doing something unwillingly.
That's your hell.
We are already taken on attitudes.
What we like and what we don't like.
I like this person. I don't like
this person. Now with this person,
I will do things willingly with this
person. I'll do things, honey unwillingly.
This maybe two people,
two aspects of life to communities,
to nations,
too many things.
This I will willingly
this I do unwillingly.
This means I've decided in my
mind this is good. This is bad.
When I hear even in
national news channels,
good guys and bad guys.
Once you have this kind of thing, you
are going to be disastrous to the planet.
It's just a question of time.
The moment you decide this is a
good person, this is a bad person.
This has gone deep into American society.
No,
there are no good people and bad people.
Everybody's oscillating between the two.
If you create a wedding, a pleasant,
wonderful atmosphere,
everybody behaves wonderfully.
If you create an unpleasant atmosphere,
a whole lot of people agnostic this no,
there are joyful people
and miserable people,
but there are no good
people and bad people
[inaudible]
the moment we think we are good,
we are entitled to
destroy the bad isn't it?
Well we've been destroying a
lot of people for a long time.
Time to stop typing because human beings
had in different levels of experience
and understanding
that idea of people.
Anybody who is not like you
is obviously bad, isn't it?
Isn't it? So those are not
like me. Must be bad people
because the basis of goodness and what
you think his goodness is decided by you.
No, you have no business to
do that. Willing means this.
I am just willing, um, 100% yes to life.
I am not yes to this
one, not to this one. No.
I'm just yes and yes to life.
If you are 100% a yes to life,
you're a woman tier.
You have a big,
I'm a will in life.
You have become sure willing that
you have no will of your own.
People ask me Sadhguru,
how do you operate with all these people?
All kinds of horrible questions.
They're asking, they're doing this,
they're doing that. I said,
my life is not about them.
It's about me.
It's about how I am.
It's about me. It doesn't matter
how they are, that's their choice,
but how Ireland is my choice.
This is my way.
No matter what they do.
I'm like this because I have not given
the freedom to anybody that somebody can
freak me, somebody can make me
angry, somebody can make me happy,
somebody can make me unhappy.
These privileges I kept to myself
each time you do the too because if
somebody else can decide what can happen
within you right now, he's in
this the ultimate slavery, Huh?
Isn't this someone else can decide
what should happen within you.
What happens around you? Of
course him. So many people decide
what happens around us is not 100% ours,
but what happens within me
lesbian,
my making,
isn't it right now just about anybody
can freak anybody because they're not
volunteers.
They're unwilling.
Wallen tiering means you
have no will of your own.
You can do whatever is needed.
You know we are a volunteer organization.
This means that all kinds of people,
most of them are not qualified
for the jobs that they're doing
and I cannot find them
because they're all in tears.
So people
coming up to me on a daily basis. I said,
Google, I can't work with this person.
She's so horrible. I gone
do it. I tell them, see,
in this world, this is the sort
of people who exist like this,
like this, like this, like this.
That's the kind of people that are not.
If you want to work with ideal people,
you must go to heaven
today,
but if you think what you're
doing is very significant,
you must learn to work with all these
horrible people you saw the world is.
If you think what you're
doing is very significant,
you learn to work with all kinds of
people. You will see hardly will.
People will do wonderful things.
Yes,
but if you want to work with ideal people,
you won't find any.
I haven't one yet.
No.
All kinds of mixed bags.
But if you are willing that you
are not yes and no as to one north,
one of the use, simply one
big ass, you will find a way.